Hello everyone, I hope that you're good.
Quick Bitcoin update for today. Today is
Friday and we only really have the New
York session before the weekend. So,
we're going to talk about the weekly
candle close, what could happen,
and of course don't expect much to
happen over the weekend because we are
usually in a very tight range of a
couple hundred dollars and
no much going on over the weekend. So,
we're also going to talk about potential
trade setup that it should happen today.
Otherwise, if it doesn't get completed
today, then we're going to close the
trade or that's at least what I'm going
to do because I want to enjoy the
weekend and I know that in the weekend
I'm not going to see much activity.
Okay? So,
let me tell you what I think so far,
okay? This is a range, range highs,
range lows, mid-range, the orange lines
are the range quarters,
and we have the deviation that we talked
about between 31,100 and 31,700
because there were many liquidations up
there.
And also stop losses. Then, when you see
deviation,
the deviation gets confirmed once price
gets back inside the range and
consolidates a bit here. This is what
happened here, okay? That's when you can
take a short and you're going to aim for
a breakout at the other end of the
range. Okay? You can notice here that's
our that's our breakout, but the only
thing is that it's consolidating
here.
And it keeps testing the 4 or 50 MA,
that's the purple line, as resistance,
but it doesn't
dump, okay? This is what I was talking
about also in the Sunday update. That's
weird, okay? So, that's what it was
telling me this week that it was very
likely to see
a Monday's false move here,
okay? To the downside to fill this week
over here and also the 50% of this week,
and then a pump, that's a short squeeze
above the 4 or 50 MA.
That's what happened if you notice, all
right? Fill this week over here.
There you go, and then come back lower
to the range lows. I don't know I've
just done.
All right, to the range lows.
And that's pretty much what's happened,
okay? Now, the thing is that if you go
into the weekly time frame,
you're going to notice
how we're still
below the range lows.
The range lows are uh 29,525.
So, today's going to be a very important
day in the markets. Well, also
I don't know if you want to see some
kind of uh false move on Saturday or
Sunday, but today is quite a decisive
day. Also, on Sunday is when this candle
closes. So, if you want to be bullish,
then you need to see the weekly candle
closing
above the range lows, okay? To get back
inside the range, and then once it's
back inside the range, you can aim for
the mid-range and also high, okay? And
in fact, you have this week over here.
You got to me?
But,
if we have a weekly candle close below
the range lows,
that's not great because you just had
then two weekly candles testing the
range lows as resistance, and maybe you
have to consolidate here even more or
even have a drop before coming back up.
Okay?
So, that's something I'm going to
discuss in the Bitcoin Sunday update on
Twitter. So, let's see how that evolves.
And then,
yesterday, I couldn't upload
a video cuz I was out. I was busy, but I
posted a couple of
charts in Telegram and in Discord.
Uh they are free, by the way. So, feel
free to join. You have the links in the
description.
And we were talking
about the idea that this is
your main support in the one-hour time
frame, this low time frame, okay?
That's your support over there.
Let me
change the color.
Okay?
Um by the way, also notice how
the range this this range quarter, this
orange line, has been acting as
resistance for quite a while.
Can you see how they set the wicks to
that level and then they drop?
Also, it's probably because it's a
psychological number.
It's exactly 30,000.
Okay? So, that's also probably why.
But, anyway, if you go back into the
1-hour time frame, this is your support,
and yesterday I set two scenarios for
Bitcoin, okay? One of them was well
around here.
One of them was
a drop below this resistance,
consolidate a bit, and then you're going
to have fun as another leg lower.
Okay? And maybe you could even target
these lows over here. And the other
scenario was to see
a stop hunt. That's basically this
candle over here.
Okay? Pay attention to this candle.
That's your stop hunt.
Get back above it.
Test this support again.
You could even consolidate a bit more.
And then, that's when you can long.
And if you get back above the 1.50
million the range lows and test it as a
support,
that's another long trigger.
And you can aim higher.
Where to? Well, you have here
this liquidity pool
over there.
Okay? So, this is the scenario that I'm
looking at right now. Um again, I don't
know if today we might see quite a
boring day. But, if we see some
activity,
then I hope it's something like this,
okay? So far, we've seen the stop hunt.
Then, we reclaim this level, test it as
support, I'm long at uh exactly 39,000
352,
because I was targeting also the 50% of
this week.
Okay? And let's see how this plays out.
Right now, price is at 29,440.
It hasn't really moved much, so I don't
know if we're going to be able to see
some activity today. But,
what I'm expecting to see is a push
higher.
Hopefully.
Test it as a support. If that happens
today,
well, it should happen pretty quickly.
But if that happens today, that's
another place where you could trigger a
long.
And then you could aim
to this liquidity pool over here. Now,
the question is is it probable is it
likely that this happens
today?
Uh I'm not sure, to be honest. I would
have liked to see some more action
during the Asian session and during the
London session. If you notice, they've
been holding above here. So, that's
that's something that is not great, to
be honest. Okay? You would have want to
see because this is the stop hunt
yesterday in the New York session.
Okay? Then they reclaim this level in
the Well, in the Asian session was the
support. And then that's when you want
to see an immediate reaction to the
upside. So, in my opinion, today we
should already be here
at 29,600 and
right now we're at 29,400. So, that's
something that I don't really like.
Um I have my uh stop
quite tight. So,
let's see what happens. Well, if we see
another hit over here, then I'm going to
be out the trade. And if it's very small
risk, and if we see a push here, then I
might just take profits instead
in this liquidity pool
over here.
All right, around 29,650
or so. So, that's what I'm looking at
today. I'm not looking at this target
for today, again.
I'm looking something more like this.
I'm not expecting that much going on if
it happens because we've been
consolidated in the Asian and in the
London session. All right? So, I hope
that's clear.
I hope that's clear. And don't let me
forget, once the New York session is
finished,
no matter what's happened, I'm closing
the trade, okay? I'm not going to have a
trade open during the weekend.
That's clear for me. So, if we are again
uh break even, then I'll just break
even. If I'm a bit be then I'll break at
a very, very small loss.
And if we are around here, then I'll
close a trade at small profit, okay?
But, that's pretty much what I think. I
think that it could be
a boring day. So far has been a boring
day.
Okay? But, if we see some kind of
action, then hopefully
it's a push higher.
Okay?
Um that's what I'm looking for today.
Not much going on to be honest. I cannot
tell you that much more because there is
not much going on
happening for Bitcoin moment. So,
I would suggest you
to keep an eye on the weekly candle
close on Sunday.
That's going to be quite important.
Also, in the daily time frame, if you
notice,
we're also
below
the range lows. We failed to test it as
support, but we are above
the daily 50 MA. So, right now we are
above some kind of support, okay? Maybe
you see some more
consolidation here, and then you can see
a breakout, okay? So, um
it's not looking
it's not looking too bad, okay? Of
course, it was looking worse here,
but then with all of this consolidation,
then it was clear that we want to see a
short squeeze.
And now,
it's a shame that we didn't manage to
hold above the range lows,
but at least we have the 50 MA. So,
let's see what develops next, okay?
That's going to be quite important.
Then, if you go into the
S&P,
um let me go to the to the uh futures.
There we go.
Wow. Okay. Uh if you remember,
uh I'm in the in the daily time frame.
Yes. If you remember, we were talking
about an idea
of
a deviation, okay? That deviation could
happen in either of these two levels.
Either at this level at
4,580
or up here at 4,720, all right?
The first level,
we've already seen the deviation
happening there.
Okay? That's your deviation. Also, this
was signaling
a strong support that should hold. So
far
so far we've lost it. We have here the
daily 50 MA. So, let's see what happens,
okay? If we
get to test the daily 50 MA support and
get back
above this support, then you can long
here again aiming for this level over
here. Otherwise, if we drop again
and lose
the daily 50 MA, then you're going to
have some kind of a phone trip all the
way to this gap over here, okay? That's
a gap in price, if you notice. So,
that's what I'm looking right now for
the S&P. Bitcoin should follow.
Okay? Bitcoin should follow. Um and also
the dollar index
I'm sorry, I don't know what I'm doing.
The dollar index
um again
no what's going on.
You have here the three tops button, one
top, two top, three tops with the
deviation.
Also below the psychological level of
100, so it went to 99.3.
Then you have the reaction. We are
holding above the daily 50 MA, so so far
it's looking good to be honest. The
problem that I see is that we have a
week over here.
Okay? So, that means that maybe
on Monday or Tuesday we come lower
to fill this week.
Test again the daily 50 MA and maybe
that's when you can see the real push if
there is a push. And also, I want you to
pay attention to what happened yesterday
during CPI.
CPI data yesterday
it was
worse than last month, but it was a
slightly better than expected. Okay?
Because last month it was at 3% we were
expecting a spike to 3.3% and it
actually came out at 3.2%. So, again, it
was worse than last month but better
than expected. So,
uh
really, when that happens, you see a
false move.
Like you can see that in the dollar
index and sometimes also in Bitcoin.
Bitcoin didn't give that false move but
the dollar index did. Check this out.
Uh so, if I'm correct, then
yeah, that's Thursday at 12:00 and 1:00.
So, 1/2 12:00 is when the CPI data came
out. You can notice here what happened.
They sold
before the CPI data and then, once CPI
data came out, they spiked price up
again.
Okay? And recovered all these zones. So,
that's your false move
for the dollar index. Now, you can see
that it's pumping and maybe
today
uh I'm I'm I'm leaning more towards
probably it's next week. Okay? But,
today maybe we can see
this liquidity pool over here
getting filled. You can see that they've
already done a big job because they've
filled already
this zone over here.
Okay? But, so far you have one, two,
and I don't want this to become a third
tap to the upside and a dump. Okay? They
have to break out through this level and
fill the entire liquidity pool.
But, so far there is not much left. All
right? So, that's so far what I'm
looking in the charts. Again,
it's Friday, the weekend is around the
corner, so don't expect too much, okay?
Don't expect too much.
Um so, that's pretty much everything,
guys. Keep an eye
on the weekly candle close. If it close
above or below the range lows, and then
for today, this a trade idea that I'm I
have in my mind. Again, I've already
entered.
I said yesterday until I am on Discord.
And I don't know if it's going to play
out because so far it's been quite slow.
Okay? But, if something happens to them
in the New York session, hopefully it's
a push higher.
Okay? That's what I'm keeping an eye on
for today. So, be very careful with your
leverage. Don't
don't go too crazy because there is not
much going on. Try to have your
positions closed over the weekend and
enjoy the weekend, guys. So,
thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you soon.